Dragonflies can fly upside down, hover,
turn 360 degrees, and reach speeds of up to 55km/hr.
They can even fly backwards
with as much skill as they fly forwards.
Now researchers have figured out how.
Scientists captured over 40 dragonflies from the wild
and placed dots along their wings for tracking.
They then recorded their flight with high-speed cameras.
When the scientists analyzed the videos,
they discovered backward-flying dragonflies angle
their bodies upward,
at a 90 degree angle to the horizon.
This changes the direction of force
generated by the wings through whole-body rotation
instead of only changing the way
their wings are oriented.
This style of flight--used sometimes in helicopters--
was found to be surprisingly aerodynamic in dragonflies
when moving backward the dragonfly’s
wings can generate force as high as 2-3 times
the bug’s body weight
This work may help engineers design more acrobatic
aerial robots—even backwards flying ones.